PHILIP GREENSPUN: Welcome back.
I hope you've got your coffee.
I see somebody has a muffin.
They'll be in a
carb coma, Francis,
I'm relying on you to answer
all the hard questions.
That's not authorized.
All right, so
multi-engine jets--
the piston twin,
the good news is,
when both engines
are spinning, it's
easier to fly than a single.
Because you don't need
as much right rudder
or really any right rudder.
It doesn't have all those
left turning tendencies,
necessarily.
The training and rating,
especially the Seminole,
which has
counter-rotating props--
all your training for
a multi-engine airplane
is flying around on one engine.
Because flying
around on two engines
is pretty much the same.
So basically, almost
all the flight time
that you accumulate during
your multi-engine training
will be with one engine pulled
back to idle or, in some cases,
stopped altogether.
You have six power levers in
a twin-engine piston airplane,
two for throttle, two for
mixture, and two for prop.
You may also have cowl flaps to
bring more or less cooling air
into these piston engines.
By FAA certification
requirements,
as I think I mentioned
earlier, there
is no required climb rate.
It may be a truly crummy
airplane on one engine.
So that's why people
say that second engine
either takes you to the
scene of the accident.
One engine expert,
Mike Bush, he said--
he came to appreciate
the Cirrus parachute.
It's not like having that
extra engine out there
on the wing trying to
kill you all the time.
It just waits there
quietly until you need it.
Piston twins have an
illustrious history.
Here is a Aero
Commander piston-driven
twin that was actually
Eisenhower's Air Force One.
This also tells you something
of the growth of government.
When Eisenhower was
president and wanted
to go to a smaller
airport, this is
how he would go, in an airplane
designed for about six people.
OK, this is probably
what you'll be flying,
which is the Piper Seminole.
It is unusual in that
the props counter rotate.
And that has some
advantages that are
beyond the scope of this talk.
It's a design from the '70s
based on designs from the '50s.
Where the problems happen--
so have a look here.
Can anybody immediately see
what one problem might be?
I'd say, the left
engine quits, and you
have to manipulate these.
What happens?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP GREENSPUN: You're
manipulating the controls
for the good engine instead
of for the failed engine
inadvertently.
So it's just an interface
that's overly complex
given human frailties.
So, what do you have to
do if an engine quits?
You don't want the
drag of that propeller
out there that's not being
driven by the engine.
So you push all of
the levers forward
and try to get maximum power
out of your good engine.
Push everything forward.
You'll have to put in some
rudder to correct the yaw,
because the airplane
is going to be pulled
to one side or the
other depending on which
engine is still running.
And then there's the old
adage, dead foot, dead engine.
So if your left foot
is flat on the floor
and it's your right
rudder that's in,
then you know that it's the
left engine that has failed.
Then you try to
verify the dead engine
by pulling back that throttle.
So you'll say, OK, I think
the left engine's failed.
I'm going to try monkeying
with the left throttle.
And if that has no effect on
the flight characteristics,
you verify that it's
the left engine.
Then you feather the dead engine
by pulling the prop control
all the way back.
If you're in a
two-pilot crew, you'll
get your co-pilot to verify.
I have my hand on the
left prop control.
And you pull that back,
close the cowl flaps.
And only now do
you have any chance
of getting an actual climb.
So imagine if this engine
failed shortly after takeoff.
It's a lot of stuff
to do very quickly.
You have to do it all right.
And if you miss even
one of these things,
you may not be able
to clear obstacles
at the end of the runway.
Now, of course, your
typical piston twin,
takeoff is a stressful time
for an engine 100% power.
But there's definitely
more engine failures
that occur en route.
So the generally negative
impression of piston twins
might have to be revised if
your primary mission is flying
around the Caribbean islands.
You might, in that case,
actually say, well,
I'd rather have
that second engine.
Is this within human
capability, that sequence
that you just saw?
Yes, in World War II
when engines weren't
being made with as much
precision as they are now,
it would be ordinary to
have one out of four engines
or one out of two engines
fail on any given mission.
But they also got it wrong.
There is one very famous
guy, Louis Zamperini.
Some of you may have
seen a movie about him.
He floated in a
raft for 47 days.
I think that was a record at
the time for survival at sea.
He was on a
four-engined aircraft.
And one engineer quit.
And I think there were about
four pilots in the cockpit.
Remember we talked about
a flight engineer also
being an airman.
So if we count the flight
engineer as a pilot,
there were at least three
or four experts up front.
And as a team, they
feathered the wrong engine.
So they killed a second
engine that was actually good.
And now they had two
engines working on only one
side of the airplane.
And it was uncontrollable.
So they went in the water
through human error.
And Cape Air has a
great track record.
They've had a handful of
engine failures over the years.
They fly piston twins all day,
every day in the Caribbean
and around New England.
And when they have a
problem, usually it's
not a complete failure.
But maybe there's an ugly
indication on one engine.
So they'll shut it down.
But they do a lot of
recurrent training.
That's what they fly
all day, every day.
The typical family airplane
doesn't get flown as often.
And the pilot isn't
as proficient.
So the capable twins are
very inexpensive now,
except for the Beechcraft Baron,
which is the most sought after.
They're a little more
expensive to insure
than the comparable single.
Just the other day, I got a
quote from my local insurance
agency called Plane Insurance.
And we found out
that if you look
at a $200,000
aircraft being flown
by a pilot that has 250
hours of experience in type
in that exact aircraft
and with a million dollars
of smooth liability,
that means no sublimit.
So if there's just
one passenger,
they would pay, oh, a
million dollars for injuries
to that one passenger.
Some policies have, like,
$100,000 per person sublimit.
Anyway, it was about 50% more
for the Baron, $3,700 a year
versus $2,500.
So there you have it.
Again, it's not insanely risky.
You can quantify the risk.
The insurance company has.
But it is riskier.
OK.
We have a lot of engineering
geniuses in this class and one
physics genius--
science.
Which one was it?
AUDIENCE: Brain in cog.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: That's
close enough to physics,
brain in cog.
It takes a lot of physics
to make your neurons fire.
Obviously, my neurons
aren't firing very well.
So, what's the limit to
a piston engine's power?
Why is it that we can't
get 6,000 horsepower out
of our piston engine?
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: Cooling.
PHILIP GREENSPUN:
Cooling is one.
Sure.
What else?
What's fundamentally limiting
our ability to produce power?
Remember, all the
power that we produce
is by burning fuel
and oxygen. Aziz?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Size, yeah.
I think that's a good insight.
It's the size of the cylinder.
You only have so much fuel
and air that you can combust.
And once you've blown all
of that up, what do you got?
Nothing.
So if you want to know
why you should never
be like the Silicon
Valley heroes
and never hire anybody
over the age of 30,
the inventor of the modern jet
engine was only 23 years old,
I believe, at the
time that the patent
was filed over in England.
He was a cadet when he
conceived of the idea
at the Royal Air College.
And he said, well,
look, these pistons--
no matter how high up you
go, no matter what you do,
all you can ever do is burn
the volume of air and fuel
that's inside the cylinder.
So, what if we just adapt
this gas turbine, which
has already been invented?
It was kind of invented in
1791 but not really practical
to fabricate at the time.
But look, we're just
sucking in all of this air.
We can probably get 20 times
as much air in if we just
vacuum it in, and suck
it into a turbine,
and then light it on fire.
So that was the idea,
the fundamental insight
for why a gas turbine is
going to be a better machine
for propelling aircraft.
He struggled with funding.
So you can see, the
patent was filed in 1930.
And it was only in 1941
that it finally got flown.
And that's a good lesson
for you entrepreneurs.
A lot of MIT startups
have the characteristic,
but they're a bit too early.
I remember, in 1994,
I built the world's
first electronic medical
record system that
had a web interface.
So that had zero
value at the time.
And about 10 years later, that
was a multi-billion dollar
idea.
So yeah, Whittle died in
relative obscurity in 1996.
So nobody else liked
this idea at the time.
I'll let you read that quote--
not totally wrong, of course.
Because it did take quite
a bit of engineering
to make it truly practical.
But that didn't take as
long as people thought.
All right, you saw
this figure before.
This is the modern turbo
jet or turbo fan engine,
where you have
this bypass error.
So the outer ring
is devoted to air
that really never
goes through and gets
burned in the power section.
And that provides a lot of
additional propulsion for not
a whole lot of extra energy.
So these are much more efficient
than the early pure turbo jet.
So just to remind you, you
have the compressor section,
where you have air
being squeezed.
Now you introduce some fuel.
It catches on fire from the
extreme heat or the igniters
if you're just starting up.
That drives these
power turbines.
And some of the spinning
from the power turbines
goes back to spin the
compressor wheels, as well
as the fan in front, which is
kind of like the propeller.
All right, what about
having to turbo jet engines?
A lot of people like to see
two engines on their aircraft,
especially airline passengers.
If you have an engine
failure, what do you do?
The answer is,
pretty much nothing.
If it hasn't been done
automatically for you already,
you can advance
the thrust levers.
If the airplane is the
yawing, that sometimes
is automatically corrected for
you to a substantial extent
by the yaw damper.
You will step on the rudder
to do the natural thing
and bring the nose back pointed
to where you want it pointed.
And you'll keep climbing nicely.
You've arranged
everything both in terms
of the design of the aircraft
and the weight at which you
took off so that, no matter
the environmental conditions,
you will be able to climb.
And you will be able
to clear the obstacles.
This can be a challenge.
If you're taking off out of
a mountainous, high altitude,
hot airport, you're not going
to have a full load of fuel
and a full load of
people and bags.
But by regulation,
you're going to be
able to clear the terrain
safely even on one engine.
Why is it so much easier?
You don't have a propeller
that'll drag back a wing.
And therefore, there's no
urgency about feathering.
You also have a little
bit less of the crazy yaw.
Because the engines are,
in some aircraft, pretty
close to the fuselage.
So basically, you can still
apply that cardinal rule
of flying jets.
If the switch has dust
on it, don't touch it.
So you don't have to
take immediate action.
All right, if it's
turbo jet powered,
though, you do need
specific training.
And you have to pass a check
ride specific to that aircraft.
So most of you guys,
except for Francis,
believe that Captain Sully was
all by himself in the A320.
but actually, anything that's
more than about a 10 seater
almost always
requires two pilots.
And according to the
type certificate,
it's not even legal to operate
even the larger business
jets with one pilot.
There is an old FAR
91.5, I believe,
that says there has to be a
proficiency check annually
for the pilot in command
of a two-pilot aircraft.
And more recently,
the regulations
were updated for
single-pilot turbo jets
so that a check ride
has to be done annually,
which is not really that
different from the insurance
requirements of annual training.
They just made it a
little more formalized
with FAA bureaucracy.
All right, turbo jets
that you might own--
the single pilot business
jet with a straight wing--
they said initially,
the Cessna Citation
was so slow that birds were
hitting it from behind.
But sometimes
safety and having it
be easy to operate by
people of ordinary skill
and people of lower skill
levels is better than
getting that last
50 knots of speed.
And that's what
Cessna figured out.
So they're still kind of
a leader in this area.
They produced the
Cessna Mustang, which
you see there at the right.
Some of the Microsoft
folks, they spun off
a design called the Eclipse.
It was supposed to have these
new cruise-missile-inspired
engines from Williams.
The engines didn't work.
So the 1500 nautical
mile airplane
became a 900 nautical mile
airplane with a Pratt & Whitney
more conventional
designed engine
that's used on some of
these other designs.
The Embraer Phenom 100
has the same engines
essentially as the
Mustang, same family.
HondaJet has an
innovative engine
designed by GE and Honda.
These have all pretty much
been business failures.
And the answer to that is the
fixed costs of jet ownership
are so high you can't just get
a T hangar for $800 a month.
You may have to pay at
one of the busier airports
$40,000 a year to have
an FBO hangar it for you.
The insurance company will
require simulator training
annually.
And you'll probably
have to have two pilots
as a practical matter
go through training.
Insurance will be expensive,
because the whole value
is high.
If you wreck a $5 million
airplane or a $10 million
airplane, that's a bad day
for the insurance company.
You get charged a lot
more for landing fees
and parking at airports.
When you're a little Cessna,
they give you a break,
because they don't want you
saying anything bad about them
on airnav.com.
But if you show up
in a Gulfstream,
they figure you probably
have a credit card somewhere.
So yeah, the Mustang,
they actually
stopped production
of that plane.
The Phenom 100 is still
going from Embraer.
But basically, I think
the Phenom 300 is--
it holds about
nine or 10 people.
And I think it weighs somewhere
in the 15,000 to 20,000
pound range.
At gross, those
are the airplanes
that seem to be popular.
The Phenom 300 is
about $9 million new.
And $3 to $5 million
used applies, including
the things like the Cessna CJ3.
A $3 million plane
could be a CJ3.
All right, what about
single-engine jets?
The problem is they're more
vulnerable to engine failure.
Jet engines are
a little bit more
vulnerable to failure from,
say, a bird strike or something
than a piston engine.
And therefore, you need some way
of dealing with the consequence
of having that engine fail.
The Cirrus jet is pretty slow.
So it could actually be
landed off the airport,
perhaps, without
too much damage.
But it has a parachute in case.
And F-16 and other fighter
jets that are single engine,
they obviously have
ejection seats.
Twin turboprops--
let's talk about those.
So if you want to land
on a short runway--
we talked about turboprop
engines, I think, on day one.
They can produce a
tremendous amount of power.
So you can have a much
bigger, heavier airplane.
But because they're
driving a propeller,
you get to take
off and land short.
They developed thrust very
effectively at low speeds.
And the prop is a huge
drag, so when you land,
it kind of slows down
and stops immediately
or almost immediately.
So the King Air from
1964 to the present
with these Pratt
& Whitney engines
that were developed in the
very end of the '50s, the PT6.
Those have been hugely popular.
When you hit a bird, it's
a problem for the bird
but not usually
for the propeller.
The King Airs and this ATR,
have an auto-feather system.
If one engine loses
power, the propeller
will automatically go to this
knife-edge configuration.
I should have said
what feathering is.
You twist the
propeller blades so
that they're edge to the wind
instead of flat to the wind.
So you dramatically reduce
the drag of the propeller.
So that airplane actually
took care of itself
or should have taken care
of itself pretty well.
You can read about that crash.
I think it was in Taiwan.
But the pilots decided to take
heroic, immediate action--
or at least, one
of the pilots did--
and shut down the good engine
instead of just leaving
well enough alone.
OK, single-engine
turboprops-- as these engines
got more refined
and more reliable,
if you look at
the PT6 design, it
has all kinds of
tubes, and hoses,
and vacuum going from one
place to another and bleed air.
You'd be surprised that
it's as reliable as it is.
But they supposedly
don't really have
to be shut down for a problem
or fail more than about
once every 300,000,
400,000, or 500,000 hours.
So after that insight,
people said, let's just
put one of them in.
And we don't need
that second engine.
It'll save a ton of money.
So the Cessna Caravan is
a great example of that.
That's that sort
of boxy cargo plane
that you saw on floats
in the other video.
For personal planes
that are pressurized
and more comfortable, the Piper
Meridian, which is down here--
this is my friend Arnold,
who is at Hanscom.
He says he funded his
airplanes, because he
was practicing during the
golden age of gynecology.
And that's what
enabled him to afford
his fancy, pressurized Pipers.
The TBM is a French
design that's
considerably preferred
to the Piper,
but it's a lot more expensive.
And the Swiss
Pilatus PC-12 is kind
of a good airplane for a mixture
of family use and charter use.
The Piper and the TBM are
too small to justify all
the machinery around charter.
All right, so
actually, old King Airs
are cheaper than these
single-engine airplanes,
but they cost a
little more to run.
All right, when you're
maintaining a jet--
I think I mentioned
this earlier--
the manufacturer's guidance will
supersede those catch-all rules
of a 100-hour inspection for an
airplane operated commercially
or the annual inspection for
an airplane operated privately.
It can get expensive.
On one of those
Cessna Citation jets
that I mentioned,
coming out with $100,000
bill from the annual
would not be unexpected.
You usually have a time
limit on the whole airframe.
And if it's pressurized,
it's getting
expanded and
contracted, expanded
and contracted and a
little bit of metal fatigue
on every flight.
So you may have a limit
on the number of cycles,
the number of times
that's happened,
and also on the number of hours.
So a 12,000-hour or 20,000-hour
airframe life limit might be
common.
For the Pilatuses,
it's 20,000 hours.
And then they have
life extension programs
where they tear the whole
thing apart and replace
some structures or, at least,
look at every structure.
People have extended them out
to about 32,000 hours, I think,
now.
There's cycle limits,
also, on the jet engines.
So the turbine blades and
stuff and disks, every time
they're started and
shut down, there's
a huge amount of
thermal cycling.
So they say, look, after
you've done that 15,000 times,
you got to throw that wheel out.
And that wheel inside the
turboprop could be $100,000.
If you guys ever--
it may seem hard to believe
now that MIT has stripped you
of all of your
savings, but if you
do have a little bit of
money at some future date
and you want to get a type
rating for your airplane,
by far the cheapest
type rating you
get will be for a big airplane.
So it turns out,
if you want to pay
flight safety for the
Gulfstream rating,
or a Cessna Mustang
rating, or whatever,
those are pretty expensive.
They're relatively rare.
Boeing 737s and
Airbus A320s, so many
were made that there's just
a wide variety of simulators
all over the world.
And for about $10,000, you can
jump in and get your instrument
proficiency back up to snuff,
as well as have a lot of fun.
All right, so as a summary,
it's a good challenge
to get that multi-engine rating.
I wouldn't recommend
practicing it
unless you have an unusual
application, like you
live in the Caribbean,
and you want
to get from island to island.
If you're nervous
and somebody says,
I don't feel comfortable
depending on this
five-year-old, 1,000-hour piston
engine that's in front of us,
the answer I think these days is
it's better to get an airplane
that has a ballistic parachute
as your backup than to have
the second engine as a backup.
And while you're formulating
your questions, I'll show you.
On the top left is
a French design.
That's called a Cri-Cri.
It seats one person.
And it's, I believe,
fully aerobatic.
So you can do all kinds of
crazy maneuvers in the Cri-Cri
if you want.
Each of those engines might
be only 30 horsepower or 15.
You can look it up.
It's a truly crazy design.
Here is an AirCam
that's an open cockpit.
Although, this one has a canopy.
That's from the Oshkosh
seaplane base, a great airplane
for flying low and slow over
remote, somewhat wet locations.
Here's an L-39 Czech
military trainer.
And there's a company called--
I think it was called
Code 1 Aviation.
They had that at
Oshkosh, where they
took a regular American business
jet engine out of a Hawker,
and they stuffed
it into the L-39
because it's cheaper to
operate and maintain it
as a lower fuel burn than
the military engines.
So you end up getting a lot
longer range out of your L-39
if you want to--
those L-39s are only a couple
hundred thousand dollars
for a nice one.
So you can actually own a
jet that's fully aerobatic,
and cool, and look
like-- people will
think it's an F-16 for less
money than buying a Cirrus.
On the left is the
ramp at Teterboro.
I said I was talking about it.
If you're working
for Bernie Sanders
and you want to start
a revolution in the US,
I would recommend starting
it right at the Teterboro
airport and just film the
people getting in and out
of their Gulfstreams.
And this is Meridian.
This is the lowest-cost
FBO at Teterboro.
And that's what the
ramp looks like.
If you want to combine two
piston engines in a jet,
I believe each of
these of is a Yak-55.
And some airshow performer at
Oshkosh glued them together
and put a jet engine in the
middle and calls it a Yak-110.
So there you have it.
That combines everything
from this talk.
Any questions?
Or should we jump
right into night?
Who wants to fly a jet?
Excellent.
AUDIENCE: So you said Cessna
Caravans are single engine.
I know they fly those
commercially in Hawaii
island to island.
How do you think
they justify that?
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Yeah.
The question is, is it OK to
fly a single engine over water
in Hawaii in a Cessna
Caravan with only one engine?
Well, first of all, the last
crash of a Caravan in Hawaii
from an engine failure, they
operated it just a few hours
beyond the manufacturer's
TBO under a special program
they had approved by the FAA.
They were not doing
anything illegal.
Everybody survived the crash.
One person was killed.
Does anybody remember who
was killed in that crash,
and what was special
about that person?
AUDIENCE: It was a
flight attendant.
PHILIP GREENSPUN: Not
a flight attendant.
It was a woman who was a
state of Hawaii employee.
What was special about her?
She was the person who
certified Barack Obama's birth
certificate as genuine.
Think about that.
So anyway, if you
really open up the PT6
and the manually would say, no,
I'm not going to allow this.
And I think in Europe--
Europe wouldn't even allow
a single-engine charter IFR
until just a year or two ago.
They said, no, this is too much.
So I don't know.
It's a balancing of risk.
I don't think it's
an unacceptable risk.
People with Pilatuses, they
will go back and forth to Europe
regularly as individuals.
But yeah, maybe there should
be a warning to passengers.
We only got one engine.
Thanks for buying a ticket.